[Musique]
chaque année la Société protectrice des
animaux organise des journées portes
ouvertes aujourd'hui on va suivre romain
Nathalie et Benoît ils viennent
rencontrer une nouvelle fois
Pablo ça fait la deuxième fois que vous
venez rencontrer Pablo aujourd'hui
pourquoi cette cette deuxième rencontre
sur la fiche de description du site là
il correspondait en tout point à ce
qu'on recherchait comme comme animal
puis c'est un projet aussi avec mon
dépous qu'on avait depuis très longtemps
pour adopter un animal plutôt de la SPA
pour donner une seconde chance à à un
animal qui a pas forcément eu une vie
facile on VI deè fois avec Romain un de
nos enfants pour voir comment ça va se
passer avec lui cette deuxième rencontre
est en train de réclamer il Com Com
Pablo est en train de de rencontrer sa
potentielle famille ses potentiels
adoptant pourquoi les faire rencontrer
dans dans un parc alors on les fait
rencontrer dans un parc pour commencer
pour être sûr que le chien accepte les
personnes et aussi que les personnes
voilà VO se rendent compte de la taille
du chien de la puissance du chien des
petites choses qui auraient à travailler
deç dans les adoption tout à fait c'est
l'animal notre priorité et c'est aussi
le confort de la famille on va pas
placer un chien où les gens sont pas à
l'aise où l'animal est pas à l'aise non
plus parce que ça il y a des grandes
chances que ça se passe pas très bien
chez eux et qu' reviennent au final
c'est un échec pour tout le monde pour
nous pour le chien et pour la famille il
va avoir besoin de ces moments là de jeu
en fait donc il faut trouver des
endroits de
verdure pour pouvoir le faire jouer al
quitte à mettre une grande longe va pas
détacher mais il faut qu'il puisse un
moment donné décharger après les
présentations balade a et ben l'objectif
est simple savoir si Pablo peut
s'adapter à sa nouvelle famille
bien rain on vous a quitté tout à
l'heure avec Pablo finalement là vous
êtes avec une une autre chienne est-ce
que c'est finalement elle que que vous
allez choisir et pourquoi bah a priori
oui en fait on avait eu quelques
quelques problèmes avec Pablo parce que
bon c'est un grand chien il est gentil
il est calme mais il a l' quand même
puissant on s'est dit bon voilà c'est
pe-être on vaêre partir sur un chien
d'un plus petit calibre donc là en fait
c'est à peu près le même c'est le même
croisement
maision et surtout elle est très très
calme très très gen tire pas du tout sur
la la pour repartir avec pocket Nathalie
et Benois doivent signer et fournir
quelques documents et payer les frais
d'adoption ce soir pocket aura une
nouvelle famille on va partir avec poet
en espérant que elle s'adapte à la
maison à notre présence mais aussi à nos
absences et
cetera un grand plaisir franchement un
grand
plaisir vous étiez venu finalement pour
pour Pablo vous repartez avec pocket
est-ce que encore une fois le dicton
c'est le chien qui choisit son maître et
est encore valable
ouais on peut dire ça ouais ouais les
deux les deux il faut qu'il une
rencontre c'est une rencontre avec un
animal c'est du vivant donc il a le
courant passe plus ou moins bien et puis
pu faut prendre le caractère des chiens
avec le nôtre au refuge de plaisir ce
sont 84 chiens 150 chats et quelques
naqu nouveaux animaux de compagnie qui
attendent encore d'être adopté